five meters down on the seabed round
Grenada 25 life-sized figures the
sculptures are not only a highlight of
their holiday here for tourists they're
also a reminder by British artist Jason
de caire Taylor about the impact of
climate change and that's why guerlain
disciple brings her visitors here she's
lived on grenadier for 15 years she aims
to bring home to her guests how the many
hurricanes have devastated the coral
reef over the past few decades in diesel
morning apple wood is quick to
understate in Mali near bay here where
the sculptures are the reef was once
very beautiful when we first came here
it had canyons and so on just fantastic
that was destroyed in 2001 the reef
practically no longer exists so that's
why we created an artificial one cos
it's the Caribbean island of Grenada
lives off the tourists who come to enjoy
its beaches and the sea
but the sea is becoming a problem rising
sea levels are eating away at the
coastline here Aria st. Louis works for
the agricultural ministry DJ oldenburger
works for the German agency for
international cooperation the erosion of
the land is just one of the challenges
they're facing on the east of the island
they meet with fishermen every day they
tell them that once there was a white
sandy beach here they're using primitive
means to try and stop the water the
Moors wave from an unwilling / tickle
teens and go back see the last very long
in last one I yeah I'm from winning team
they know any water from the other tips
on the area don't know so we keep our
new not right you so allow them to
prominence so your solution the people
don't want to move so they have to live
with the consequences of climate change
I wanted to make sure that he understood
the we is him and me because he is the
one who's actually living here has the
idea of what it was before that he's
looking for and is currently being
impacted it's the rainy season but for
this time of year there's far too little
rain a disaster for the farmers Edmond
roquat has the water is fruit
plantations twice a week he's taken out
a ten-thousand-dollar loan to pay for
pumps and irrigation systems and now
this I wet my am I cantaloupe my
watermelons and I saw they are giving
them water body bowen so I said
something is wrong so when I open the
top our sprinkler one of the sprinkler
was blocked so I open it and when I take
my my mouth to pull off the clip I
realize when I run my tongue and my lip
the water was salt his irrigation pool
is fed by groundwater but that's getting
salty because sea water is seeping up
through the ground eater houghton burger
and Arya son Louie fear that it could
soon affect public wells
they've brought a water expert to the
island he's inspecting this 70 meter
deep well it supplies around a thousand
people with drinking water the well is
still intact and luckily the water is
not salty
just as well for there is hardly any
alternative here well infancy as air
pegasus the island is very mountainous
so people have to invest in expensive
pumps and infrastructure for freshwater
that's why we have to ensure the wells
account functioning they also seek out
the islands freshwater reserves the
Germans team check the water volume and
create maps for locals showing them
where the water sources are this is all
in preparation for more hurricanes the
last major one in 2004 destroyed ninety
percent of infrastructure here including
water pipes what this being is if you
mention OCS that's why it's important
for people to know where they can find
such small decentralized sources of
water that they can use to survive to
drink me to wash and to cook with
coughing to come
on the neighboring Island the climate is
even drier there's not even any ground
water here people have to rely on
rainwater and collecting water is
impossible if it doesn't rain
welcome to cooking here at this hotel
they built a subterranean cistern it's a
huge investment for such a small
enterprise yeah we stole the water okay
very very very fresh and pure and clean
mm-hmm you could have a try but
sometimes even that's not enough and
they have to buy in water from outside
and if that's in short supply they just
hope their guests will be understanding
such scenarios can't be allowed to
happen in five-star resorts like this
anyone paying a thousand dollars a night
isn't expected to put up with shortages
of any kind and so the owner has
installed low-flow showerheads from
Germany they use a third less water but
during very dry periods there can be
shortages so then they produce fresh
water with their on-site desalination
plant but that consumes huge amounts of
energy making water production a costly
matter trucking it in is a very
time-consuming and laborious operation
so it's actually much more easier to run
the desalination plant when we need it
guerlain disciple wants her guests to
always find a little paradise here with
enough water in Germany water is taken
for granted doesn't she ever think of
going back
me no definitely not yeah not implying
nothing you ask me how we're solving the
problem we will solve it it's much
easier here on a small island like
Grenada than in Germany I'm cozen
Deutschland it seems one thing people
living in the Caribbean have in
plentiful supply is optimism and at
least the first steps have been taken
you